the roads have been swept
and the fires extinguished in some of
south africa's largest cities
but the damage caused by days of
violence
cannot be set aside
the unrest erupted in a fragile land
battered by wave upon wave of
coronavirus
and the trouble will make the current
surge of infection significantly worse
many of the individuals involved in
looting
simply don't care they don't care about
the rules
and they certainly don't care about
wearing masks or
social distancing and so we are likely
to see
some super spreading events especially
when they got into
you know several of the big shops in
large numbers
without masks that's going to create
you know super spreading events
that's the last thing south africa's
beleaguered health system needs
infection levels in johannesburg
exploded
after the delta variant took root and
the region's hospitals
have been overwhelmed lacking
insufficient beds
patients are often held in casualty
departments
for days this video provided by a member
of the public
leading experts are scathing
in a province such as how tang where 25
percent of the population live
our hospitals are completely overwhelmed
but at the same time we've got
beds that are literally vacant in the
hospitals and we can't actually use
those beds
because some official in some government
official
forgot that you actually need to have
health care workers available to
actually
staff those beds as the country's
hospitals struggle
community groups have stepped in running
ad hoc
clinics and ambulances that do emergency
house calls
since the third wave has eaten we've
been working
seven days a week was hardly any rest
the paramedics donned their suits and
were led to the bedroom of an 84 year
old
called muhammad davids anka
don't worry don't worry about anything
everything is going to be okay all right
he contracted covid a few days earlier
and was finding it difficult to breathe
and his daughter said he wouldn't eat or
drink we see
he is severely dehydrated i can see
he's severely dehydrated sort of doing
the work
of the of the doctors and nurses in
hospitals
it's my day yeah
how do you think he's doing as you see
you know i'm not used to seeing him like
this
yeah it's hard i lost my mother
two and a half months ago
her father passed away a few days later
one of more than two hundred thousand
south africans who've lost their lives
to the virus
across the road the caseins were
watching and worrying
from the garden fence we did not
be too scared to god the couple
are eligible for a jab although south
africa's vaccine rollout
has been slow and inefficient
nevertheless
they've made their minds up we have to
go we have to have to go why
why have you not had them yet uh
are you a bit worried about vaccines yes
too mind a little bit but uh what
we've decided now you've decided now yes
we
we must go less than three percent of
the population
have had a vaccine and the unrest has
damaged the roll
out at a crucial time in durban
supplies were disrupted while nearly 50
000 vaccines were destroyed
in the looting we would have you know in
this period have vaccinated
close to half a million extra people at
high risk
you know in the elderly group so i
i think all around we are sitting in a
situation
where we have been set back quite
significantly
the government must rebuild the rollout
and prepare for the surge
in a country that has been pushed to the
limit by the pandemic
and the discontent expressed here should
serve
as a warning to us all john sparks
sky news in johannesburg